about the new book he co-edited mirror
work 50 years of indian writing
at 9 45 pm a tour of baldwin's book barn
in west chester pennsylvania
and a quarter after 10 p.m the chairman
and ceo of random house alberto vitale
talks about his career and the book
publishing industry
our guest is author frank mccourt he
joins us to discuss his book angela's
ashes
[Music]
franklin court author of angel's ashes
right before the show started somebody
said to me if i ask you
where this cover come came from they
would tick you off
that would yeah well what i've been
asked a million times it's well it does
look like me anyway that kid looks too
well fed who is the kid i don't know
somebody something scribner came up with
some marching from some strange place it
does look like lim it could be me it
looks like some lane and limerick
but he looks too he looks too
even but i never i never had bare feet
my mother always made sure that we had
shoes even though they were falling off
her feet but when other kids went around
barefoot but we didn't we were too
snobbish so that when they when you saw
this book you didn't know that this
picture where it came from or who i had
no idea at all there was some dispute
about it my wife said that it's wrong to
put some unknown kid she wanted them to
put me on but they decided their life
and people like it in general that gives
the flavor of the book
cunning fructive kid on the street
when did you get the first idea that you
wanted to do something like this
write this book uh-huh
first of all i always wanted to be a
writer but i didn't know that i wanted
to write about this this lane and
limerick the slum because anybody who
comes from the circumstances doesn't
want to write about it you're ashamed of
it
you you don't have any self-esteem
so i it wasn't till i i
somehow began to gain
some
approval or acceptance from my students
in new york for friends of mine
in social circles i started talking
about growing up with limerick and i
suppose some of the stuff i told them
was amusing and they'd laugh and because
the whole poverty is so absurd some of
the stories i told them were so absurd
they'd laugh and they'd say you should
write this when you're going to write a
book i've been hearing this for years
when are you going to write a book what
are you going to write about but no more
insistent than little
voice in my head write the damn book
and i've tried it over the years i wrote
i wrote a version of it 1969 i think
called if you live in a lane
but it was derivative imitator i was
gone i was imitating everybody ocasion
joyce and henry wayne and uh evelyn wall
imagine me writing like evelyn i tried
to be smart ass upperclass british right
that none of it worked until eventually
i found my own way
where is the high school you taught in
new york uh east 15th street fifteenth
or first avenue but that wasn't the only
one i taught i i think i was in
three different high schools
mckee vocational on staten island silver
park on the lower east side
briefly in in fashion industries high
school on west 24th street and then in
stuyvesant high school how many years
a total of 20 well close to 30 including
substitute teaching
so when did you sit down and first start
putting words on paper for this book for
this one that that version i did if you
live in a lane uh in 1960 no it's not it
goes way back it goes way back to my 20s
when i started jotting things in
notebooks things that my mother said the
sayings from the neighbors because there
was a lot of funny stuff despite the
poverty there was we had a lot of
eccentrics
wandering around in them like who if
they were here they'd be locked up today
yesterday but uh
there were there were characters all
over the place
who's this okay that's my mother in the
middle that's uh when my brother mike
got married he's
he's the one to my mother's right
my brother alfie is on the left mike
malik and myself and my mother that was
mike's wedding about 30
i don't know 32 or 33 years ago his
first wedding where are your brothers
today uh maliki the bearded one is in is
in new york he's an actor he's writing a
book
and uh alfie
and mike runs a bar and restaurant out
in san francisco ceo corvin
and alfie as they all went into the bar
business
uh people used to say well when you got
into the barbers and i said when my
brothers go uh become teachers at the
alfie he we had great hopes for him
because
he's the only one who had any kind of
education he went to to secondary school
and i only came over and we all thought
he was going to go to cologne he went to
colombia briefly and uh we thought he'd
become a lawyer or something like that
but he instead he opened the mexican
restaurant
be all the irish but you ever better
open the mexican restaurant and it's
still there in new york no no it's gone
now no gone lost punches it was very
popular in the upper west side
who's this
that's my mother when was this taken
uh
i think that was says on the back 1979.
some barons and third avenue we would
take her out occasionally she loved
going out
uh because she she enjoyed the good time
you could see she was a a large woman
that of course that was because she was
sedentary but she loved she loved
parties
how many children did she have in her
life seven
how many of them are alive today four
what happened to the other three well
she had
she had
six children in five and a half years
and uh they were including twins
and uh um
three of them died in that five and a
half years margaret the little girl and
the twin she did margaret died in in
brooklyn and the twins died in ireland
so they died
probably bronchial pneumonia or
something like that something
preventable
and that's what the death of the little
girl i think drove my father crazy
because he was mad about her
and i know that i remember the kind of
attention he paid her which he didn't
pay us he was very good to us he was a
very kind gentleman when he was sober
but
but and
my mother went into a deep depression
now if that if the death of the little
girl
drove him into into a depression and
drove him to the bottle you can imagine
what it was like then when the twins
died in ireland what year did the
children die
uh
margaret died in 1934 i think and and
the the twins in 35
oliver died in may of 35 in eugene
november
35
and in the meantime my mother got
pregnant again the month that uh oliver
died
and where do you fit in the family i'm
the oldest you're the oldest yeah
who's this
oh god that's my father
i don't know who he's holding there
fiona all fiona yeah yeah yeah this this
maliki's uh
a granddaughter that was taken in
belfast just before he died i think yeah
he lost all his hair and he had an
accent that was indecipherable you need
subtitles
to to hear so that's in belfast where he
died he was he he made his way when he
went off to england during the war and
knocked her on then got into trouble
drinking made his way back to his
father's farm where my grandmother was
and then wound up in belfast in the
pension when was the last time he saw
him
in his coffin in 1985
before that i saw him in 1971 when
belfast was erupting
it was the worst summer they had
what was your relationship with him at
the end
inconsequential i never saw him
if i did see him it was a formal
conversation it was very hard to get
into a an intimate conversation with him
and
if i s if i if i were to look at this
from the outside i would say to myself
so why didn't you go back and talk to
him
but i think uh i i had a feeling that
there was no point in her or that he
wouldn't come through he was so blocked
in every way he'd say well how's your
how's your mother
and how's your brothers and her or and
that was it and then he'd look out the
window and he'd drink his tea and there
was no getting through to him
were you ever close to him i wasn't when
i was a kid
i didn't think i was close to him there
was a time in the book where you talk
about he kissed you for the first time
in the hospital when i had typhoid fever
this and this is a national
characteristic i think of the irish this
poetic mercurial flamboyant race we
don't go around saying i love you the
word love was something that was
reserved for god or babies i love you
darling you talk to babies or maybe
horses that win
but uh not for uh not for a personal
relationship i used to think when i was
a kid when people said i love you that
was only for something on the screen at
the lyric cinema
we we never heard it i never heard a
mother saying i love you to her joy and
my brother maliki once had an experience
he was nine i think this may have
changed the course of his life somehow
emotionally
he was in the kitchen he was nine years
old and he said to my mother he was
overwhelmed for some reason and he said
to my mother ma'am i love you
and she looked at him
and then later on he's there at the
kitchen fiddling around and her friend
brady hannah comes in from next door and
my mother says brady do you know what he
just said to me what angela he told me
he loved me and the two of them had a
good laugh and i think maliki sings with
the floor
so you had to be careful about telling
people you love them
what's this oh god yeah that's the uh
mongrel graveyard where we took my
mother's ashes to be sprinkled it's an
old medieval abbey outside limerick so
she died and she died in new york and we
had a cremate and we we took her back
there she used to say
i want to be buried with my own people
in in in in mongreat
i
she was a large woman you saw from that
earlier picture i said do you know
the cost of transporting your body to
ireland
so we cremated her anyway took her back
and had five or five or six days of
grief in celebration
when did she die
1981 december of 81.
oh yeah
oh my that's the uh the kind of ashes
that we were sprinkling
it was a very strange occasion because
maliki was there and our wives were
there and um a group of friends
and i think we'd all drifted away what i
remember mostly
was our awkwardness and what and usually
we're not caught short for words but i i
think maliki and i felt a bit awkward at
on this occasion because we simply
didn't know what to do usually you have
a priest taking care of it but i just
there was a pause we sprinkled the ash
and then
i'm the oldest son so i'm the chief
mourner i suppose so i just started
saying hail mary follow grace the lord
is with a and that was it and we blessed
ourselves and climbed back over that
gate again because that's a national
shrine now and you can't get him but we
had to climb over the gate
the same gate that's me and my daughter
maggie yeah and sheila brown and sheila
brown right who's she brown she's a
friend of our brian brown's wife
they and they have it they they own a
kind of a normal castle or keep
is it uh
maybe ask it differently how does it
feel to be so public with your life
i haven't had time to reflect on it
since last september how to be because
i've seen i know i know people who are
public because they used to hang around
the lion's head bar in new york and i
knew pete hamill and people like that
would have been public for years and
years and years and i'd see them come
and go and i and i'd i'd be on the
periphery of that crowd and uh
that i was as what they call an america
only a teacher
only a teacher they're journalists and
writers and poets
i'm only a teacher and i was i i had i
was always on the periphery in a sense i
was like my father an outsider
now
uh
people look at me oh
they look at me
it's like ralph ellison's book the
invisible man peop the people don't see
you until you i wrote a book
i taught for 27 years and nobody paid me
a scrap of attention then i write a book
about slum life and i'm an expert on
everything
and we got all this from
a young man that's in your family oh
connor yeah
who is he he's doing a v who are these
two men that's mike my my brother he's
the third in the in third in line to the
immense mccourt fortune and he's the one
in san francisco
he's out there
with his wife john he has four kids and
connor is a cop in new york who's become
a family chronicler
archivist video man
and he's very he's very enthusiastic
over capturing the history of the family
he's done a video
we know yeah
we we know and we're going to know
everything right
we're going to show some of that a
little later on there's just some more
pictures there you have the goods on me
yeah this is a photograph that i you
know it's the brothers but uh what you
know what year of this i can tell you
this was last year yeah this was the
gran tuccino restaurant in new york the
one the night my book was launched
again the same alfie mike maliki and
myself same lineup from the wedding
picture 30 years before
that that that was a that was it that's
what they all that's one of those rare
occasions i think when we were all
together because usually when we got
together there were uh there were
fireworks
i don't know old uh
old grievances but they the book seems
to have healed a lot of that stuff with
the result that we we all went to
limerick in october for the launching of
the book in ireland it was the first
time we'd have been in ireland together
for over 40 years
because mike is out in san francisco and
even though three of us live in new york
sometimes we don't see each other for
long periods of time
we have another one here with the same
group but there's somebody in the middle
ellen my wife
well that's outside the redemptor's
church in limerick
we were that's when we were there last
year that's when the four of us got
together we went up to the redemptive
church but i think ellen ellen was
getting ellen was getting the tour of
our of my of my slum childhood when did
you marry ellen 1994.
first second wife third
i've married different states rhode
island north carolina and finally and
blissfully california where did you meet
ellen
in the lion's head bar but we we it was
arranged it wasn't just one of these
things where i wandered in off the
street she had a friend
uh uh
deborah and who was going with a guy
named jerry poynt and it was a friend of
mine and they arranged it was a
matchmaking and it worked although ellen
was a little wary of me considering my
history and i don't blame her
what's your history well i've been
married twice before and being a bit of
a wanderer
and uh how many kids do you have one
from the first marriage maggie
she's in santa cruz in california how
does this all work out in the catholic
church
i don't care
i'm i suppose i'm out i'm as was a mix
communicator no i'm not because i was
never married if you're not married
within the church what you what you do
doesn't matter you're simply committing
the sin of adultery
uh so i i haven't uh i haven't tried
transgressed and
on holy matrimony if i got married in
the church then they take it seriously
so i'm not ex oh yes i am excommunicated
for something i did in in the 1930s in
in my 30s i went to trinity college in
dublin
which was
a forbidden catholics by the archbishop
john charles mcquaid
any catholic who goes to trinity college
is excommunicated automatically
that's been lifted now
why was that the case
he he was just uh he was a tyrant
because trinity college was regarded as
as a nest of of uh protestantism and
atheism and free masonry
but i went there anyway to get a phd
what do you think of roman catholicism
just
in general institutional catholicism i
have no time for it i know individual
priests and nuns who are doing literally
god's work but
the church the church has to catch up
with what i don't know but it has the
case it's dying
i just read there was one little
statistic last year in limerick that
caught my eye in the irish times that
they they uh beatified the founder of
the christian brothers edmund rice
at the pope beat a fighter that last
year
one person joined the christian brothers
in ireland as compared with 39 10 years
ago so that's a dying order teaching
order and that's that that that that uh
that shows you how how few people want
to go into the church anymore were you
ever an altar boy
no
why not my father wanted me to be an
altar boy and made it made me learn the
the latin made me learn all the
responses he knew the mess backwards and
forwards the priests part and the and
the boy's part so he trained me and i
memorized all the latin and he had me
kneel in the kitchen floor and limerick
and then the in troy boyd altar day
quave
and uh he texts me around the corner
then to the st joseph's church and
and the sacristan there who took care of
the church just looked at me and said we
don't have room for him
my history is a history of having doors
shut in my face
now they're flinging wide open i can't
there isn't a door shut against me
anymore only good things happen to me
why do you think this book
is
has excuse me has been on the
bestsellers forever
has been on top 40 year weeks after the
first hit the best seller it's a mystery
really messed up it's a mystery to me
yeah
today i read a review on the new york
review of books
that's a that's a that's a journalist
slightly to be feared because they can
have they can trot out some very acerbic
reviews
there was an enthusiastic review by a
man named neil atchison
and i thought i thought i'd get a mixed
review from this because they're not
known for their enthusiasm
so you have the new york review of books
you have uh the new york times and all
kinds of time magazine book of the year
newsweek
los angeles times and i i'm a bit tech
in the back because i thought it was a a
a kind of a simple narrative
in the in the tradition of what they
call the shanicky in ireland the old
storyteller
so
they find i
that
it's it amazes me what what the
reviewers are finding in the book
it's a comment and devilera's island
they're on catholicism and they're
finding how
how what a consciously clever
writer i was which i didn't know about
who's devalera the devil the prime
minister of ireland who who who
who i think kept the country back 50
years behind this time which is all
right because uh
one time george bernard shaw was asked
uh
on the last day
of the world where would you like to be
and shaw says ireland why because the
irish are always 50 years behind the
times
where was emma and devalera born new
york where were you born
brooklyn
i think i'm not sure if i was born in
brooklyn in manhattan my mother would
never tell me she she always shied away
from that why i don't know because i was
yeah i was conceived beyond the sheets
i saw i was the cause of sin i as you
say
if frankie was the cause of marriage
they had it was a shotgun wedding
and i was i was what appeared five
months after their wedding
did that bother you when you found it
out it did yeah because uh one of my
friends
told me i was a bastard
and there was no way of getting around
that he said i was doomed and it was a
sin that could not be washed away with
the baptismal water
so i'm doomed i'm excommunicated because
of trinidad and i'm doing because i'm a
bastard
were your parents catholic when they
died
they
my mother would give lip service and she
was she believed in it but she didn't go
to church that often i think she had
confession before she died
they do they get you you're in a coma
and they bring a priest anyway you
mumble something the thing it's less
formless less rigid than it used to be
you can go into the church and make a
general confession so i didn't just say
i confess but in my time you had to go
in and detail your sins
with which kept us all in a state of
terror because you know an adolescent
boy is constantly finding himself
irresistible and that's that's the sin
of impurity
and that was one of the big boy the one
of the big sins in limerick
i think i was in a constant state of
impurity
and terror of the priests
to it reached a point one time where the
priest didn't believe that i was in a
proper state of repentance and told me
get out of this confession box and don't
come back to you're truly sorry and i
walked out of there i felt i was doomed
if i'm hit by a truck now that's it
eternity
in flames
have you talked to any priest since the
book came out oh yeah a number briefly
but they i have uh
i have a special fire now i have all
kinds of files for my the mayor and i
have there's one called negative stuff
and i have a special fire for priests
and nuns
and they all uh they all like
oh that's the bishop that's tata [ __ ]
that's the mayor of limerick
uh mr orhander when i went back to
limerick last year
i was received with open arms
that lit the city was so proud of me
catholic city catholic i thought
catholic glimmering yeah received you
with open arms yeah 600 people showed up
at romani's bookshop that night
waving books and and inviting me off for
a pint
uh
but this time when i went back the the
little change sea change back in july
opposition yeah in july for what reason
uh for the launch of the paperback
another tour of ireland and uh by now
they've read the book and there were
some vocal critics like did they
confront you yeah they did
uh the same bookshop on mayhem is where
i was received with wired the claim last
october there was a line another line
for the signing of books and
a woman at the head of the the queue
said hey you're disgraced you're lemie's
national school the things you said
about them boys i said no he didn't i
said where did i say that and you did i
said show me in the book and and then
they hustled her off
then another woman said this a bit of a
hassle behind me she said you're going
to get a bit of a hassle so this grim
looking character comes up he takes a
picture he's about my age he takes a
picture of his pocket it's the picture
the school the class
picture from the book puts it down in
terms of you do you know what that is
i said yeah that's the class picture
from lemmy's
he said now where am i in that picture i
don't know it's over oh he said you
don't know how grand we are coming back
from america
now he says
you're a disgrace to ireland you've
besmirched the fair name of limerick and
you've destroyed your mother good name
and here's what i think of your book and
you tore it to pieces
the paperback
that's the lane
in limerick
where you lived yeah when yeah
1940s 1940s
late 30s to the 40s
what is it for someone who's never seen
the book what is it they actually get
what's the time frame
it starts i suppose with my mother and
father meeting this is just the the time
ends uh 1929 to 1949.
so that's 20 years except by i was born
in 1930
in in new york and taken to ireland in
1934
and i left then again in 1949.
so it's mainly the the story of me and
my family from 19 from our arrival in
ireland to my leaving in 1949.
another book
oh yeah um
i didn't know i'd be writing another
book i wanted to write angela's asses
now i want to write the second book
because i think that things i want to
show the effects of poverty on the
emotional effects
on on a human being it happens to me me
i'm the one that
i'm the expert on me as of both but it
it i'm i'm because of my teaching career
in new york and because of my dealing
with all kinds of kids poverty drugs
uh divorce
i want to show that psychological damage
done
to a young man by the poverty and and
and that that very tyrannical church and
the crazy nationalism that we were all
subjected to in devil air as ireland
where he was pouring more money into
into uh preserving the irish language
than he was into the slums of ireland
how many people live in ireland
now it's a population about
overall four and a half million for the
32 counties yeah how many counties
you've been in have i been in i've been
in all of them
uh
ever i've been i've been no i've been in
all of them yeah i was going to exclude
dairy but even in derry what's the irish
thing
the irish thing
now
but as you refer to in your book what's
the what do you how do you define what
the irish thing is
this
it's a kind of a trinity of of
nationalism and um and uh uh
of catholicism and immigration
this is these the characteristics of
of the each nation i think has certain
characteristics another characteristic
of the irish which i thought was
disappearing was the drink
that's how it's referred to the drink
not drink not alcohol the drink
and when i was there last week i noticed
it it's still it's still the swelling
that goes on is unbelievable and i don't
know where they get the money it's a
booming economy so but it's always they
always seem to have the money for the
drink and it's destroyed so many people
so many families do you drink
yeah moderately i just don't have the
capacity for it how about your brothers
they don't three brothers don't drink
anymore they all had problems with it
and they gave it up
i said they went into the bar business
and they were their own best customers i
suppose for a while what is it about the
irish and the drink why in that little i
think i've tried to figure that out
there was nothing else
in in a country in a country that was
completely uncluttered
compare the irish with the italians say
without the rich culture down there in
in in italy uh architecture and music
and
and wine and uh
joie de vivre we didn't have that we had
a kind of a gentiles grimness in in the
northern country uh there was po there's
plenty of poetry song uh love of the of
of the landscape of nature and of women
back that that love poetry died for a
long time in ireland
uh
uh
in recent times is it the the aft after
after the famine i think something
happened to the irish soul
you have a audio book
you read it yourself
four and a half hours long
why did you read it yourself i didn't
want any uh i i didn't want any uh
affected broadway actor fiddling around
with it broadway actors always pause
always meaningful pauses i just wanted
to do it myself because i think i could
invest it with what i meant to have
it wasn't easy but where did you do it
in uh on in at scrivener
in new york they have their own they
have their own recording facility how
long did it take you a week
well that's not as bad as a friend of
mine donald donnelly who did ulysses
took him 15 months
how did you do the audio
they put me in a room and i sat there
and uh i i read what they gave me to
read
there are parts that are omitted from
that that i'd like to go back and put in
but there's also a full
and unabridged version coming out from
recorded books did you do that i did
that too yeah at the same time you did
this i did it long after this how long
did that take you that took me
a month
and that was that was hard because they
were very precise
you
i think they can hear your hair growing
those technicians and those recording
people the slightest
intake of breath that might interfere
with the word i had to go back and do it
again but it's very efficient now they
just do it right away and go back over
it wanna run a two minute and thirty
second clip of the audio and listen to
it and then ask you what this is all
about
okay
two days later dad returns from his
cigarette hunt
it's the middle of the night but he gets
maliki and me out of the bed
he has the smell of drink at him
tomorrow at this he tells us we must
promise to die for ireland
we will dead we will
all together we sing kevin barry
on mount joy one monday morning
high upon the gallows tree
kevin barry gave his young life
for the cause of liberty
just the lad of 18 summers
sure there's no one can deny
as he marched to death that morning
how he held his head on high
there's a knock at the door mr mecadori
ah maliki for god's sake it's three
o'clock in the morning you have the
whole house walk with the singing
ah then i'm only teaching the boys to
die for ireland
you can teach them to die for ireland in
the daytime maliki
because urgent dance is urgent
i know maliki but they're only children
babies you go to bed now like a decent
man
bed down
what am i to do in bed
her little face is there day and night
her curly black hair and her lovely blue
eyes oh jesus then what will i do
was it the hunger that killed her then
of course not your missus was nursing
her god took her he has his reasons
one more song then before we go to bed
good night maliki
come on boy sing
because he loved the motherland because
he loved the green
he goes to meet a martyr's fate with
proud and joyous mean
true to the last o true to the last he
treads the upward way
young riding macaulay goes to die on the
bridge at tomb today
your die for ireland won't you boys
we will die
and we'll all meet your little sister in
heaven won't we boys we will died
what's that all about
that's uh
that that takes place in brooklyn after
my sister died she was 21 days old when
she died
and he went he went demented
and it was a habit of his to get herself
because he was a he was a frustrated
patriot he was born in the wrong time
i think he would have been very happy if
so if if he had
fought the english and been caught and
hanged he would have died singing rodney
mccarley or kevin barry
but he he this was his way of continuing
his
his his the excitement that i suppose he
felt when he was in fighting in the
troubles in ireland and he would drag us
out of bed in the middle of the night
and make her sing all these songs
uh and i think i i my mother was
appalled everybody was apart but we
enjoyed it
because it was very it we'd sing it was
we got out of bed in the middle of the
night we'd sing and he
this is was a connection with the father
that
any any excuse for making a connection
with him was was wonderful
how many years actually did he live
85
was there ever time that you knew him
that he didn't drink
i think towards the end he stopped maybe
in the last few years in belfast he had
the pension he he didn't go out that
much anymore he drank his tea
how long was he on the dole and what is
the dough in ireland
is unemployment
and he was always on the door you you
most people most of them working in
so-called working men were on the door
you'd get about 19 shillings
which was about
three dollars a week in american terms
in those days
uh it was it was it was not enough to
keep a family going
and how did he get to the old money and
then spend it on
drink without your mother getting her
hands on the money
he'd go down all the men would go down
on thursday morning to what they call
the labor exchange to get their money
unlike america if you're going to
unemployment you only have to send in a
statement i think once a week or
something like that but you had to
appear at the labor exchange every
morning in limerick in case there might
be work and everybody used to laugh over
there was never going to be any work and
you'd sign this was to make sure that
you weren't working
so you get your your your money on
thursday and all the men would go down
there was a big day
and and you'd see women and it was in a
lane in limerick and you'd see women
cluster the both ends of this it was an
open-ended lane women waiting for the
men to head them off before they went to
the pubs
and he my father was uh was very very
conscious of his dignity but he didn't
want my mother there at all he wanted to
be able to go to the labor exchange get
his money and then go home which he did
often but often he went to the pubs and
and he he just drink the whole damn
thing so my mother threatened him she
said she was going to go down to the
labor exchange
and get the money from the man the clerk
which she did and he was shamed forever
because the woman came into the labor
exchange and took the man's doll
that's not what a woman is supposed to
do well she wanted to make sure her
children were fed that's not what a
woman is supposed to do
and he lost his dignity when did he
leave your family 41. the end uh
the end of the end of 1941. where'd he
go england he went off to work in the in
the factories in england in coventry did
he ever send money back once or twice he
sent a few pounds it wasn't enough it
was just a gesture
i don't know maybe somebody persuaded
him to send the money back but he left
us to starve
when you remember the worst moments in
your early life what were they like
uh
waiting for the telegram boy the the
telegram boys on saturday and saturdays
used to deliver the telegrams to their
families whose fathers were in england
most of the families like the means or
the downs across from us would get their
telegrams solid steady men sending the
money home from england and we'd wait
all day and saturday and we hope and
hope and hope and we knew then that you
could hear the angelus always ringing at
six o'clock in the morning noon and six
o'clock in the evening but you knew bong
bong bong when the engine was wrong in
the evening
and the telegram hadn't been delivered
that was it you're going to face another
week
of uh
starvation effectively what did it feel
like to be hungry
you know you just you never felt you
would never never satisfied you never
had the full feeling and we always
we used to mix up such fantasy fantasies
there was a bush that grew and limit out
in the country a little green green leaf
and a little red berry which was in
there that were really inedible we
wanted we used to call that bread and
cheese
and we'd eat this we'd eat these leaves
and these little berries and imagine
there were bread and cheese and i
thought sometimes someday i'm gonna have
a big bread and cheese sandwich
that was my dream at one time my mother
did get some money she got a job as a
child woman she got some potatoes
and a bit of corned beef and and and
jelly and custard and this we had this
on a sunday and she said we're not going
to eat all of this today and i will save
something for tomorrow and uh there were
about four potatoes left over boiled
potatoes and so with the jelly and
custard i'm never counting one of my
early crimes now uh and she put in the
windowsill she had a little curtain like
a larder
so i came home on monday from school
there was nobody in the house and i
looked went over and looked i said i'll
eat one potato
or a half and i couldn't stop eating the
potato i ate the four potatoes and all
the jelly and custard and boy did she
kill me
she knocked me around the place that
night and my brothers hated me it was
the biggest crime i've ever committed
did you ever have a cheese sandwich oh i
did
i finally i had the experience of being
full when i came to the states
going into horn and harvest when i got a
job what was that that was an autumn at
the old argument where you put nickels
in to take your take your food out of
these little compartments i stuff myself
but heaven i experienced culinary heaven
when i was drafted into the army and
sent to germany
where i was stationed in bavaria where
they had the
quartermaster cooking school
gi joe
[Laughter]
what year
that was 1951. oh boy
[Laughter]
yeah where did you spend your military
or how many years in two years in
bavaria south of munich in a little
village called langries
up in the bavarian alps i had a great
time
you came to the united states
permanently in what year
49.
how did you get here
oh
well that's another story of thievery i
had one i worked in the post office
delivering telegrams then i worked at
easton's wholesale new news agents which
is like i the irish barnes and nobles
and then in the meantime i got a job
with this old woman writing she was a
money lender a shark a loan shark and uh
what was her name uh mrs fanookan
and she she uh she needed somebody i was
delivering a telegram and she said uh
are you any wish mart
[Laughter]
i said i can read it right she says half
the people above the lunatic asylum can
read and write can you write a letter
and of course i could write it out and
she hired me to write threatening
letters to dilatory customers i was to
threaten them that if they didn't pay up
they'd go to jail like three oh well i
threatened with all kinds of things i
let my imagination run wild and i was
very successful she'd pay me three pins
for each letter and sixpence if it was
successful how much money is that in
today's time i suppose uh the
irish money was much more powerful than
it is now
uh
it would be about uh
uh maybe 30 cents for each letter
and then uh 90 cents say if it was
successful and you tell the story about
how your mother would hear from her
friends that they'd gotten this
threatening letter yeah and they all
they all said it was a horrible thing
who would write a letter like that to
their own class of people a a person
like that should have their fingernails
pulled out and be boiled and all the
walkers and i'm the one and i was
listening to all of this and i just i
felt awful
that i had to write these threatening
letters i felt but i felt so powerful at
the same time that my letters were so
they were so effective but i made the
money and then
i was putting away in a post office
savings account even to the extent where
she'd give me money for stamps to mail
those letters and i would keep the money
for the stamps and stick the letters
under doors so all of this was going
into the post office from my fare to
america but right before you came to
america though you slipped in somewhere
and took a little money didn't you well
she died
she used to send me out on friday nights
for butler sherry to the pub and um uh
when i came back she was dead in the
chair so she had her personal store from
her purse and she had money upstairs in
the trunk under the bed along with the
ledger that she kept
her there in the chair right yeah
her person dropped to the floor
and but i averted my my eyes for her
because i was terrified but still the
main thing in my life was to get to
america
and i think i would have robbed
somebody's grave to do that i had to get
out of ireland did you report the fact
that she was dead anymore no i didn't i
just walked away nobody knew i just go
in the back door nobody knew who i was
so um uh i i got the fair to america how
much was it well it was 59 pounds
altogether to come to america and i was
saving saving saving i was also i also
worked for eason's uh news agents and
part of our job was to
this is my experience as a sensor of
magazines we had to go through the
magazines and make sure
if there's something had escaped the
censors in dublin we were responsible in
the local easterns for
for uh offensive material a one of the
there was a john london's weekly that
had a page on on
birth control
and the call came down from dublin did
you send out jonah london's weekly yeah
so i'll go get in tarot page 16 it's
about birth control we had to go running
all over the city cycling and running
walking and in the van
rush into these news agents and tear out
page 16.
another picture here of the brothers
you're in that picture one of the
brothers missing which one yeah mike is
missing mike is in san francisco and
then your nephew again because i want to
show some video yeah
conor mccourt a policeman in new york
city and he's got this
documentary yeah
when did he start it
i think uh he's he and i were talking
over a year ago about about this family
stuff i was interested in getting a
whole composite picture and he came to
ireland in may 1996
i was over there with my wife ellen we
were we're on combination of promoting
the book pre-publication so connor came
up with his video camera and and did
some footage over there and then he
continued in new york he's been toiling
away at it ever since
and getting better and better and he's a
cop that rides a bike around yeah he
rides a bike ride he's he's the terror
of of the upper west side drug dealers
that and that what the the the the
dominicans don't know he's he's fluent
in spanish so when they're talking about
miramira the drugs are in a in a garbage
can connor knows what they're talking
about he goes off and grabs the drugs
and he grabs them so
uh i they
he he's very he's very colorful very
effective cop
we have a vhs copy of some of the things
he's done we're going to run three
minutes and 19 seconds of it and the
audience will get a chance to meet your
brothers and
let's let's watch this and see what they
think
basic time it was a very short time
really but
for that i remember my father
vaguely
and then it came time
but the sun was always shining we were
always playing in the streets up there
there were always games out in the
streets and
stuff and everybody and everybody was in
and out of everybody else's houses
we all knew each other
in fact this little scar i have up over
here was clocked on me by one agnes hen
and she dropped a rock on my head you
know
and she lived right next door to us but
she was she threw a rock over the wall
and
guess who was on the other side of the
wall me
and uh
but it was like there was one there was
the thing about it there was kids all
over the place at that time
it was a very busy little place
and like i said the other thing i always
remember was it was always warm up there
it was always warm days it seemed to me
anywhere
what about the rain huh
ireland's supposed to be famous for that
yeah but i think there was a probably
about 1939 40 i suppose
one day i even remember reading about it
at the beginning at the beginning of
world war ii they were saying what a
long
hot somewhere warm summer it was all
over europe
and it seemed to be that way then
mr mind is uh
she was a sweet singer
a good
speaker she had uncommonly good speech
and she was a reader
which is an affliction we all caught an
addiction affliction whatever you call
it
we all ended up with the same thing
she was as i said from uh
outside of limerick from mongrel
i remember uh
she didn't have an easy life i know that
but she always she was a great woman
for a party certainly in her latter
years
i was born at home in barack hill
as far as i know that's the family
history
it was a
turbulent time we didn't have a great
deal
what's your saddest memory
the saddest memory
is
the twins the death
of the twins
eugene and oliver
they were very charming
pair of kids i remember them well
although i was much older i was a year
older
but so we were exposed to death very
early it um
the finality of it was
not apparent at that time because they'd
always tell us you know they're
they're very happy and they've gone to
heaven and
they're playing with the angels and the
baby jesus and they have everything they
need
and all that and we would say well why
can't they if they're why can't they
come back
in order mike alfie and maliki
yeah
their ages
uh how old are you now i'm 66 malik is
65.
uh
mike is uh 60
and alfie is 56.
anybody not like the fact you did this
book
in the family yeah no
unless they're talking behind my back
but they've all embraced them
enthusiastically did it affect their
lives i think it did because um now
maliki is writing a book he was
approached
to write a book and uh he's doing a
thing on on his experiences in new york
it affected their lives because it
brought us all together and it and and
then the the next generation of kids
they're they they know more about what
we came from because we we talked
intermittently down the years about and
humorously i think we didn't we didn't
burden them with the whining about our
poverty but now it's i think it's
between the two covers and they can read
it and i think they're very proud uh
that the name that the tribe is is uh
has some prominence now
what's the second book going to be and
when will it come out
i think it'll come out in the spring of
99
i'm trying to get to it
it's and it's about my my life in new
york but mainly
what i discovered what i learned as a
teacher
i stood in front of those classes for
over 27 years
talking exhorting evoking
and learning mostly i used to say to
them in stuyvesant high school in
september and january when we get these
new classes in so by the end of this
term there's one person in this class
who who will have learned the most and
that's me because i want to learn and i
would learn something from each time for
instance we did hamlet each year if you
do it over and over it just it keeps
a pawn the play keeps revealing itself
and and they uh and they by their uh by
by by my admission to them that i was
almost illiterate and that i really knew
as much about a poem as they did because
they had the idea if you read uh
a yates poem or tsl the teacher knows
what it means
teacher doesn't know you can only you
can only guess they thought
the teacher i said no we don't know the
poet himself sometimes is puzzled by
what he has written so we we uh
i think it helped them realize uh uh
there's no end there's no conclusion
there's no ultimate answer
we're all in the same box what was the
racial mix-up of your class initially
next i'm not mix it up
initially stuyvesant was it was
jewish
bright kids from the upper west side and
all around new york and then slowly
there's there was a an asian
incursion if you want to call it that
chinese and a lot of korean kids and a
few uh a few more
exotic
uh sikhs and pakistan is coming in but
all
uh
not like the usual new york high school
which is which is largely
african-american and hispanic because
stuyvesant high school is a special
school we have to take an examination to
get in 700 openings ever every year and
14 000 kids take the exam
so you had the cream of the crop
in one way it was easy to teach but in
another way you had to stay in your toes
there was no such thing as giving those
kids busy work
oh yeah busy work they'd know then you
then you they could see right through
you so i was forced
uh
willy-nilly to be honest with them
and that's i think that's the main thing
i gained out of it to be honest with the
kids and styles and in previous schools
like sewer park we had the mixture of of
chinese dominicans and so on there i
learned i think to speak clearly
directly simply
tell the story simply because you had to
reach such a wide variety of
of kids did any of your students know
these stories that you feel with them
yeah did you tell them in class yeah a
few of them
and what's the been reaction have you
run into your old students all over the
place last uh in washington i've run
into san francisco one in in san
francisco there was
16
showed up at a reading
and i think i always had this uneasy
feeling when i was teaching so it's
supposedly teaching writing i had this
uneasy feeling they're sitting there and
they're saying oh yeah you're telling us
how to write why don't you write and
they would say after some of my stories
oh mr mccoy you should write a book
you should write a book you write a good
book
so now i've written the book where did
you write the book physically mostly in
pennsylvania where house milford
pennsylvania why there because we uh
ellen and i rented a house down there a
few years ago and then we got married
there on the banks of the delaware and
then we decided this is where we wanted
to be so we bought a house you live
there now no i live in new york i have
an apartment in new york but we
we lose no opportunity to run to the
delaware river
when you write what time of day do you
write in the morning
like my father
of it i i have a lot of his early
morning habits what time do you start
sometimes seven eight something i'll
make coffee and give it to ellen in the
bed
i have a very good husband
everybody should have me for a husband
if they want coffee in the morning
how long do you ride on any given day it
depends on how it's coming some days i
just want to put a pin through my brain
because it's so difficult but on
on certain good days i would write nine
or ten pages
how long you give up after a certain
amount of time
no if it's coming it's coming and i stay
with it i'm not i'm not i'm not like uh
uh anthony trollopro used to write 3 000
words every single morning before he got
on his horse and inspected post offices
i couldn't do that i didn't have a set
amount what do you write with on i have
a this is an armchair and i have a board
and i put it on the arms of the chair
and i put a notebook on that and i write
in pen i write the text in the right
hand they put make notes on the left
page
as i go along and then i i type it into
the computer
when was the last word written
for this book
oh with the last word was written the
day before the manuscript was due what
was that what was that that was uh uh
the manuscript was due on november 30th
i told them because i know i pick out
certain dates november 30th 1995 i said
i'd have i'd have it in them because
that's the birthday of my idol jonathan
swift so i said i'd bring it in and the
night before i called ellen at work i
said when you come home i'm gonna i'm
not gonna write the last word till you
come home
and uh she came home and i had the
notebook and i wrote the last word and
then we had champagne and the next day i
deliver the manuscript
are you now financially a wealthy man
yeah
what do you think of it well they won't
help me to write the next book
[Laughter]
all the millionaires in the world that's
that's the me i had to do this now i
have to do that why do we burden
ourselves like that
i could sit back now for the rest of my
life and roam the world and see in
faraway places and but i have to write a
book
who's this
oh that's
oh that's my back my i i had a house in
brooklyn
in cobblehead that's my daughter maggie
when she was three years old
what's she like oh she's great she's 26
now she has a little girl she's out in
santa cruz
maggie has gone to school
oh god maliki and myself
at yates's grave
yeah cast the cold
life and then sligo yeah candy slider
yeah yeah why are you there
malik and i did a show called a couple
of blackouts about growing up in ireland
and then our adventures in limerick and
in america rather and we we did it in
sliger at the
uh hawks well theater
in 1985 oh god me
in the army
fort dix
new jersey with my old girlfriend emma
mcmanus and my mother
visiting the recruit
when you see this picture we showed it
earlier
any anger left no i no
i just feel sorry for his wasted life my
father's wasted life
if it wasn't for the drink he would have
been the perfect father what's the best
thing about him that you remember
his um
what he had in his head the stories the
legends
uh his sensitivity to irish history he's
yearning i think he's yearning
to have been uh for
he's yearning for for a part in the
struggle who named the book and here's
again the picture of your mother and the
voice who named the book who named the
book angela's actually i did
well i intended to go all the way up to
her death in 1981 when she was cremated
and like we took the ashes back but i
hadn't i and i thought i was going to go
that far but my editor nan graham said
i took it up to the age of 19. she said
that's good
that's the kind of born in america you
go to ireland you return that the
odyssey is complete by the way have you
gotten over the irish tradition of not
telling people that you love them oh
yeah yeah
the brothers the same way oh my brothers
are the same yeah
so it's not painful any longer no no
we're pretty profligate with our
emotions
here's the cover of the book with a
picture not of frank mccourt
angela's ashes is the title of the book
and we thank you very much for joining
us thank you everybody
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777